so in the last couple of minutes that we
have left
um well you mentioned you're going to
some Bitcoin conference uh has that uh
has your thinking evolved on bitcoin
fixing this where this could be anything
from uh any nuclei I love those guys I
know you guys one of the reasons is that
we fought
we went through this whole sort of
interpersonal drama stupidity then they
got kicked in the teeth when the price
of Bitcoin relative to Fiat went down
and they realized that I wasn't their
enemy I was their friend I mean I'm not
I'm not one of them I'm not putting on
the laser eyes all that kind of stuff
but
I want them to be the big dogs at least
they're excited about life they're
excited about something that's new
and a lot of them have made money and
sooner or later you know one of the
things I took this guy Robert Breedlove
is one of the big Bitcoin guys uh to the
University of Chicago I wanted to show
him what happens when you look at
academic economics uh from the point of
view of a different academic subject
any time these guys want to they can
start endowing chairs in universities to
make sure that professors are present
who can say no what I'm trying to say is
we're acting powerless and we're acting
like we have an infinite amount of time
and we don't and what what we need is we
need a tiny number of the world's
smartest richest people
to wake up and recognize you're all
going to die and you're not going to be
able to take that with you you could at
least figure out
how to maybe save all of humanity in
your descendants because there's a huge
thank you for whoever it is that
actually steps up to the plight I don't
know what they're doing we we've
produced the wrong Elite for sure
foreign
[Music]